newly released body camera footage shows
the tense moments after a car chase an
hours-long standoff and an
officer-involved shooting in Oklahoma
now you can come on man
you can do this
come out peacefully it happened on
October 18th in Oklahoma City officials
there say just after two o'clock in the
morning police zeroed in on a drive-by
shooting suspect officers followed in a
squad car but lost sight of the suspect
a short time later they found him at an
apartment complex
on the ground
the suspect now identified as
20-year-old Degen Oliver hid in front of
a van as officers called out to him he
refused to come out and allegedly began
firing shots
come out to me
it's fired shots fired Oliver then ran
off and fired shots at another officer
who had just arrived on the scene
investigators say he was armed with a
handgun and rifle at the time he stashed
the rifle in front of a parked vehicle
but used the handgun to continue
shooting
police say Oliver barricaded himself
inside an apartment building and fired
multiple shots at officers who worked to
secure the situation
there you come on man
you can do this
come out peacefully responding officers
worked for hours to convince Oliver to
leave the apartment what's up come on
come on it's gonna be okay
okay it's gonna be okay okay keep coming
to me just keep coming keep coming
it's all right you're gonna be all right
it's gonna be okay I promise baby I
promise you Oliver was booked into the
Oklahoma County Detention Center on
multiple counts including shooting with
intent to kill the officer involved in
the shooting Keegan Burris was placed on
administrative leave as the
investigation continues for the latest
developments in this story and all
things True Crime stay with long crime
Network I'm Sierra Gillespie